jacques français éméchés ont enfilé le
premier président non gaullistes de la
vème république
né en 1926 valéry giscard d'estaing
accède à l'elysée en 1974 en battant
françois mitterrand à 48 ans il devient
à l'époque le plus jeune président que
la france ait connu depuis 1895 le
polytechnicien et énarque se veut alors
l'incarnation d'une modernité
il fait voter entre autres l'abaissement
de la majorité à 18 ans et la
dépénalisation de l'avortement mais il
mène aussi une politique économique de
rigueur à la fin des trente glorieuses
en 1981 il perd son second duel face à
françois mitterrand la construction
européenne prend alors une place majeure
dans sa vie politique député européen de
1989 à 1993 il est aussi président en
2001 de la convention pour l'europe
chargé de rédiger la constitution qui
sera rejetée par référendum quatre ans
plus tard il ne cessera de vrais à
l'international comme sur ces images où
il rencontre le président russe vladimir
poutine en 2015 sur la situation en
ukraine
sa carrière politique est aussi local il
dirige la région auvergne pendant 18 ans
à partir de 1986 en 2004 il se retire de
la vie politique pour siéger au conseil
constitutionnel l'année précédente il
est élu à l'académie française
la carrière de valéry giscard d'estaing
est aussi marquée par plusieurs affaires
la plus connue révélé en 1979 est celle
dite des diamants de bokassa
d'après le canard enchaîné il aurait
reçu des diamants de la part de l'ancien
empereur de centrafrique alors qu'il
était ministre des finances en 1973 le
dernier scandale en date remonte à mai
dernier il est visé par une enquête pour
agressions sexuelles
après la plainte d'une journaliste
allemande l'ancien chef d'état a fait
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
publiques le 30 septembre 2019 à paris
lors des obsèques d'un autre président
de la
public jacques chirac qui avait été son
premier ministre de 1974 à 1976